hey everyone diavolo here today it's
simple
we are going to be going over the
unrivaled potential of jiu-jitsu
kaizen's current leading female role
and my favorite female character right
now in the anime the breaker of faye and
destroyer of destiny
maki zenin but just before we get into
all of that if you are neuroned here and
don't want to drop your next hot meal
randomly into a puddle then make sure to
hit that subscribe button
then leave a like and you'll be blessed
with good fortune warm meals and free
anime body pillows for life but enough
of that
let's get into the video so i just
wanted to start off and say like
wow chapter 150 blew my mind i've seen
all the itachi comments and i
like absolutely love them i really
wasn't sure where gekko was going with
this
after how amazing chapter 149 was but i
think this is something that he has
mastered perfectly
just when you think the series is
reaching a peak he grabs out a missile
and raises that ceiling exponentially
he also does this with his characters
raising their strengths in a way that
isn't a random ass pull given to them
for the sake of plot
there are specific conditions that must
be met to evolve as a jujutsu sorcerer
we just witnessed maki go through this
evolution
into something that is now strong enough
to keep up with special grade users in
the series
and i personally believe that she has
broken the mould of the xenon clan that
she set out to break earlier on in the
story
so unrivaled potential means having no
rival being incomparable or having
supreme unrivaled greatness this title
floats around the jujutsu kaizen
community
landing on certain characters who are
unrivalled in terms of greatness
people like serugojo ididoryuji megami
fushigoro and toji fushigoro to just
name a few
these characters are all i believe to be
unrivaled in their own ways
you may be slightly confused by what i
mean by in their own way
well i'll explain yuji is unrivaled in
terms of no one that we currently know
of can rival yuji with his natural
control over sukuna and being able to
ingest his fingers with no ill effects
to his mental capacity
megami is said to have the potential to
even surpass the current strongest
sorcerer in the jiu jitsu world both
gojo
and toji are personifications of this
unrivaled potential when it comes to
opposites this being the absolute peak
of cursed energy manipulation with gojo
and toji's destiny defying use of his
five senses and
physically gifted heavenly restriction
we got to see both of these immeasurable
forces go up against each other in the
gojo past arc creating what i think to
be the first
fight in this series where we witnessed
the true potential of both
what a cursed user could become and what
a heavenly gifted user could grow into
if the right condition was met
this condition was that you had to rid
yourself entirely of the cursed energy
you possess
something that we thought was entirely
possible but only through the use of
heavenly restriction at birth it just
seemed like toji was an extremely rare
case in which he was
energy-less from birth and that
definitely can still be possible
though we won't know until we get an
exact explanation of how toji completed
this restriction but i like to think it
was pretty much identical to maki
i've explained this in my twin theory
video so be sure to check that out for
better context on the idea that toji had
a twin
which was the catalyst to unlocking his
heavenly restriction
exactly like maki so i believe because
maki has unlocked this restriction
completely
that she has almost risen to the level
of toji who in my eyes is in the top
three in the jujutsukai's universe
which i think puts maki probably in the
top 10 in the jiu jitsu universe
as silly as you may think it sounds maki
in chapter 150
killing 40 plus members of the kukuru
squad including first grade sorceries
like junichi
ogi chojiro and heavily wounding ranta
is just like when the reincarnated toji
flew into dagon's domain and dispatched
the special grade with ease
not saying that maki is on the same
level as toji as nanami
maki herself and naobisa were slowly
outclassed by the insanely strong degon
though easily i see maki getting to his
level within this next arc
i really feel all she will have to do is
strengthen her senses to the heightened
level that toji was at we can see in
chapter 150 that these senses are
already at a higher level than usual
as he felt the menacing aura that
chojiro sent off just before he sent his
rock hands flying through the ground to
try and restrain her
maki will become someone that is
untraceable to a cursed energy user but
unlike toji needing a curse to carry
around his weapons which can put him at
a disadvantage
unless he digests the curse maki won't
need to do this
as long as she has megami with her this
is because of megami's bottomless well
technique where he can reach into a
storage room and access weapons in the
heat of battle we already know that maki
and megami are an extremely great pair
together so it's not too much of a
stretch to imagine this duo could
probably become the most
ruthless duo in the entire series megami
who has the capability to become
stronger than the strongest jujutsu
sorcerer
and maki who will become an invisible
invincible demon that lurks near his sea
of shadows
so to end it off maki is someone i
believe who will become
unrivaled when it comes to a physically
gifted restriction surpassing toji
all she has to do is destroy thanks to
mai maki has unlocked the strength
needed to run the new zealand clan that
maki will build
atop the bones of the defunct dead
members who tried to oppose the
potential she possessed
anyways i hope you all enjoyed the video
i really enjoyed making this
and talking about the future
possibilities and potential of maki
zenon if you guys are new around here
and want to keep up to date with the
latest jjk
one piece and tokyo avengers content
make sure to subscribe and leave a like
if you do enjoy my content as it really
helps out with the algorithm
also leave a comment and let me know
what you all think about maki her
potential and where you think it's
headed
but for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you all
in a bit bye
[Music]
you